the first time the three blonde heads
were on national TV was as my backing
band because one of the songs that were
just two dumb that sting wouldn't sing I
played all the instruments I sang it and
by some weird Miracle the BBC Radio One
put it on the playlist and I've got a
hit and I had a secret identity because
I was a member of this lame punk band
and uh the only way I could escape the
curse of the police sounds kind of funny
after all these years but I wore a mask
and pretended you know nobody knew who
was and so when we got on national tv
top of the Pops I didn't want to be a
guy standing there a solo artist and so
I got my two Chuckle Buddies to join me
on the stage and be my band so ladies
and gentlemen I am here for the brag
there was stingo his first time on
national TV in a gorilla mask miming to
my Baseline now it must be said that he
did get his revenge in the fullness of
time